if you want to get the most out of your
galactic adventure you're going to need
a ton of cash you'll naturally accrue
units as you explore and sell the
minerals you mine but if you're like me
that isn't quick enough if you're just
starting out I'd recommend taking on
submissions head to your near space
station and talk to this fellow
most of these missions consist of simple
fetch quests but they can net you a nice
stack of units or a rare component you
can also grab multiple quests at a time
and as you complete more missions you
can unlock more lucrative objectives
after you've jumped a few systems you
should stumble on a freighter being
attacked by pirates take out the Pirates
and board the freighter the captain will
give you his vessel and you'll be able
to pick up missions from here for the
most part these missions offer a bigger
payout and usually consist of simple
fetch quests with a few more hazards
thrown into the mix unfortunately you
can only accept one mission at a time
from your capital ship
if you find yourself jumping from system
the system pretty regularly make sure to
stop at every Space Station you can to
check out the technology merchants
where's the better the scanner module
you have the more units you'll get for
scanning fauna and flora with an s-class
scanner I made well over a million units
in a few minutes just make sure to land
on a planet that can support life if you
want to make the big bucks though you
should look into flippin cryo pumps you
get new blueprints from abandoned
warehouses so be on the lookout for
those it may take a while but eventually
you will find a cryo pump blueprint next
you'll need two ingredients thermic
condensate and hot ice when the next
update launched you could easily find
traders with these materials however
after the latest patch on PC I can't
seem to find traders willing to sell
them if you have the blueprints for
these items you can craft them yourself
if not you can search planetary depots
instead there are a ton of ways to make
money in no man's sky but these are only
a few of the most efficient ways we
found so far if you found some good ways
to make money leave it in the comments
below thank you for watching